a recipe for banana oat muffins calls
for 3 4 of a cup of old fashioned oats
you are making one half of the recipe
how much oats should you use so if the
whole recipe requires three-fourths of a
cup and you're making half of the recipe
you want half of three-fourths right you
want half of the number of old-fashioned
oats as the whole recipe so you want
one-half you want one-half of
three-fourths one-half of three-fourths
you just multiply one-half times
three-fourths and this is equal to you
multiply the numerators one times three
is three
two times four is eight and we're done
you need 3 8 you need 3 8 of a cup of
old of old fashioned oats and let's
visualize that a little bit just so it
makes a little bit more sense let me
draw what 3 4 looks like or essentially
how much oats you would need in a normal
situation or if you're doing the whole
recipe
so let me draw
let me draw let's say this is represents
a whole cup
and if we put it into fourths
so let me divide it a little bit better
so if we put it into fourths
you put it into fourths three-fourths
three-fourths would represent three of
these so it would represent
one two three it would represent that
many oats
now you want half of this right because
you're going to make half of the recipe
so we could just split this in half
we could just split this in half let me
do this with a new color so this this
you would normally use this orange
amount of oats but we're going to do
half the recipe so you'd want half as
many oats so you'd want half as many
oats so you would want this many oats
this many oats now let's think about
what that is relative to a whole cup
well one way we can do it is to turn
each of these four buckets or these four
pieces or these four sections of a cup
into eight sections of a cup let's see
what happens when we do that so we're
essentially turning each each piece each
fourth into two pieces so let's divide
each of them into two so this is the
first
this is the first piece we're going to
divide it into two right there so now it
is
two pieces
and then this is the second piece right
here we divide it into one piece
and then two pieces
this is the third piece so we divide
into one two pieces and this is the
fourth piece or the fourth section we
divide into two sections now what is
what is this
what is this as a fraction of the whole
well we have eight pieces now right one
two three four five six seven eight
because we turned each of the four we
split them again to eight so we have
eight as a denominator and we took half
of the three fourths right remember
three fourths was in orange let me make
this very clear because this drawing can
get confusing this was three-fourths
right there so that in that is
three-fourths this area
this area in this purple color
is
half of
of the three-fourths let's think about
it in terms of the eights how many of
these sections of eight is it well you
have one section of eight here two
section of eights there three sections
of eight so it is three-eighths so
hopefully that makes some sense or gives
you a more tangible feel for what it
means when you take one half of 3 4.